今日は人類の夢について話そうと君たち我々人類の夢とは何か知っているかねそう
空へ行くことだ我々は古く昔から虎を飛ぶことを考え様々な挑戦をしてきた飛行機を
つくって z 機をつくったりあらゆる手段を利用して我々は空を飛ぼうと考えるらが
人類自身で空を飛ぶということは未だ
立ってい我々は様々な努力をしていろいろな強く理想に添えことだけを考えた
うわぁ
まあ簡単に言いますと紙飛行機というものがありますよいやこれねすごいよまじで
ビッグなハイものでいやいやーこれはすごいでしょこちら ik てかいいつの紙飛行
機公家に飛ばせる自分で作れてこれが世界記録のキングサイズだっつってね紙飛行機が
入ってます
まあ紙飛行機を買ったのか
関連してこれないんじゃないんだけどね以上800円とかした気がすんだけど紙飛行機
ではずじゃないんですよ
hot なぜここでホットといったのか
自分でも
分からなかったいやいや水時代も変わりましたらでちょっと開けていきましょう言いの
書いてありますねほど紙飛行機の解説当分書いてありますいう了解でありますね
滞空時間ギネス世界記録29秒らしいです大外羽仕方とかどういうふうに陥ったらいい
方だったんじゃなく
はこれ難しいなぁこれらシダーはガチなヤツだよ
これすごいいろんな神高原それからですね sky king in gray くらい
や
コンコルド無線 lan サービスて絶対知ってるスペースシャトルがたまあすごい
なぁ機構リングなんてやってもうすごいかも髪切っ大きいですからば切っちゃって
今季税すらないのもありますけどねまあでも今回の意味はそこじゃないっすよ僕のお
目当てはこちらなんですねしっかり勤務なんてを作ってる
感染してますからねそれにして外競技ですから辰平権で世界記録月に入れたって安い
もんだよもう
せこいよ阿見飛行機が付いてるんだよな子はこれ大丈夫かトッピーねこれかこれが世界
一な紙飛行機使いキングですこれが世界一かこれ普通で何か俺も作れる気がせ
そんなことはないよきっとすごいと思うんですよ99をするはいける気がする
滞空時間のギネス世界記録は29秒になんだね僕はそれを超えて40秒8を出します
任せてくださいとこれは今日世界の記録を塗り替えでは行こう
完全にバカにしてる人と思われちゃうよ上にあげたらいいですねいきます
トゥーワン
あれおかしいなもっと
a 待ってくる本当に世界市七保
合間にすごいよかったに曲がってるんだしっかりとコナー
羽の象牙の長さ5月になっているとちゃんが末でおります
ほら
うわーっ
もう
ぐうっ
黒い
ずらーっといやいや俺ちょっ転載
第3のチーム b をしようぜ
寝よ下へ好きの[ __ ]に当たったロールの数がポッ
をあの第3のチームに当たってますした多く
なぜ世界一がないふゆーちん子入って
びっくりさ中どっ
ドアてたんですあ
今感じた俺が感じだこれ強くだけださんっ
フレーム
えっすごい楽しいマーク物欲だけ楽しいですか
4 o
さあさあさあ
もどって来るよこれもう戻ってくるんですけど
me
アグ the ってやつ
もう
秋津箱のちょっと爪にカスタマイズした方に気がすんだよね外人は申し訳ないんです
けど私なりのカスタマーにとしてみましょう
スピードだけを止めた最強の紙飛行機でてきましたこれぞ世界取れないことなんです
いいです
4日
います
はぁ
ます
持った
しています